welcome back to new rock stars I'm
Hector Navarro and today we're breaking
down the Marvel Comics that may or may
not serve as inspiration for the rumored
upcoming Doctor Strange sequel that may
or may not directly set up the events of
Avengers Secret Wars time Runs Out was
an avengers-centric crossover event that
built up to 2015's epic Secret Wars
comic book miniseries and I'm going to
tell you everything that happens in that
build up but before I do just real quick
a reminder that new rockstars is now
three channels this main one the break
room and the Deep dive so make sure
you're subscribed to all three in case
this topic is explored further across
the new rock stars verse the fall of the
Marvel Universe begins in Avengers issue
number 35 and goes through to issue 44.
New Avengers issues 24-33 and even the
last five issues of Avengers World Plus
a Sprinkle of Miles Morales the Ultimate
Spider-Man which we'll get to there is a
ton to go over so I just want to take
another brief second to say if you're
even slightly interested in this go read
these Comics yourself they're amazing
and here's a Hector tip put on the
Avengers movie scores while reading just
to ratchet up the amazingness the comics
are full of so many incredible moments
and fantastic character interactions but
I can't possibly mention them all here
so please check your local bookstore or
your local library or read them online
with Marvel unlimited and I promise
you'll be glad that you did and now into
the breakdown at this point in the
Marvel Comics Multiverse incursions have
begun an incursion is a collision of
Worlds that is the harbinger of the
death of universes and some major
players are already trying to do
something about it after the Illuminati
refuses to destroy other realities just
to save their own Namor does it for them
and assembles the cabal to continue
helping him the cabal consists of Namor
Thanos Proxima midnight corvus glaive
Maximus of the Inhumans terrax the truly
enlightened a former Herald of Galactus
From Another Universe Galactus with a K
and Black Swan a woman who escaped her
dying universe and not at all a
ballerina played by Natalie Portman
before the main time Runs Out storyline
begins we got to talk about the tie-in
issues of Avengers world that show us
how some of the characters are in the
spot they're in Before Time runs out and
a story arc called Before Time Runs Out
For example we see how Smasher real name
Isabelle Izzy Kane a former sub-guardian
of the shiar Imperial Guard and current
Avenger learns she's pregnant and how
she tells her partner Cannonball real
name Sam Guthrie former member of the
New Mutants and current Avenger and it's
really sweet and romantic and nine
months later their baby boy is born we
see the seeds of doubt in Namor maybe
beginning to regret his actions we also
see how Sam's former New Mutants and
current Avenger teammate Sunspot real
name Roberto Acosta uses his ridiculous
wealth as the CEO of DeCosta
International to buy advanced idea
mechanics and puts Ames evil scientists
to work on trying to solve this
world-threatening problem well after he
takes care of the current scientist
Supreme and his loyal aim henchwoman
Monica rapacini can you say hostile
takeover Sunspot starts building up a
new Avengers his team too and asks
teleporter manifold real name Eden
fessey to help by taking them to the
Savage land to recruit a refugee from
another destroyed Universe the super
strong Hyperion next up is Shang Chi who
is going to factor into Roberto's plans
accessing a new power at a quarantined
former site of An Origin bomb on Earth
the way he accesses that power is super
cool because Sean Chi is super cool and
we also see how Thor odinson now
unworthy after the events of original
sin is brooding in the Savage land
hanging with Hyperion and the indigenous
scientists there called The Children Of
The Sun or the zebra kids odinson as
Thor has come to call himself get some
of his Godly groove back after those
pesky former aim leaders attack the
Savage land which was all part of
sunspot's plan to juice the Thunder God
for what's coming next knowing that he
would defeat the former aimed scientists
pretty easily and Namor reaches out to
Mr Fantastic and Hank McCoy beast and
that's where we're at Before Time runs
out so now it's been eight months since
Steve Rogers who who's aged since his
super soldier serum was neutralized by
the villain the iron nail but who still
looks like he's an incredible shape
learned what the Illuminati was doing
and declared them enemies of the
Avengers that they would arrest the
Illuminati consists of Reed Richards
Beast doc green which is what Hulk is
going by these days kind of like a smart
Hulk or a smug Hulk Black Bolt of the
Inhumans black panther t'challa Captain
Britain Brian Braddock yellowjacket Hank
Pym Amadeus Cho doctor strange and Iron
Man and they go into hiding only Iron
Man goes missing and no one knows where
he is because he was captured by the
cabal but Amadeus Cho being one of the
smartest Minds in the Marvel Universe
breaks into Shield station Golgotha
formerly Avengers Tower to try and get
access to Tony Stark's Tech but he's
intercepted when Maria Hill sends the
best Shield unit they have the Avengers
which consist of Hawkeye Clint Barton
Captain Marvel Carol Danvers Captain
America Sam Wilson War Machine drones
piloted remotely by James Rhodes
Invisible Woman Susan Richards who's
determined to hunt down her husband Reed
and all of them led by that sexy Silver
Fox Steve Rogers The Man in the chair
now more is getting more desperate and
more full of regret because the cabal is
just relishing killing entire universes
and it's bumming Namor out he dines with
Victor Von Doom and his adoptive son
Christoph Vernard in latvaria asking for
his help and stopping the out of control
cabal but Doom refuses that pesky pride
of his if only Namor had come to Doom
first instead of throwing his lot in
with those Psychopaths speaking of the
cabal they've taken over wakanda and the
necropolis the wakandan City of the Dead
where previous Black Panthers are buried
and where black panthers t'challa and
shuri escape from thanks to members of
the Dora milaje and hata zarase
sacrificing themselves so their Panthers
can live to fight another day but shuri
decides to stay behind presumably
meeting her demise fighting off the
Invaders and back in latvaria after
Neymar leaves Doom checks in with his
team trying to solve the incursion
problem his scientist the Mad thinker
and his captive Owen Reese the molecule
man molecule man who boy he's a whole
thing we're going to get to more of him
later star brand real name Kevin Connor
and night Mask real name Adam blackvale
which is the most metal name Ever by the
way are two people who were ascended by
the last white event and got near
unlimited Powers because of the
multiversal incursions they became tools
of the builders the universe's first
sentient race that built systems to
control space and time and were supposed
to replace the Builder's older tools the
gardeners the abyss and the alifs star
brand and nightmast joined the Avengers
once the Builder's existence was found
out and they helped the heroes fight
them off in the Builder War now they're
out in deep space and they encounter a
problem the ALF From Another Universe
being pushed into hours they head to
Earth to try and get to the bottom of
this when they realize Roberto da Costa
is dealing with the same problem
thankfully aims multiversal transporter
machine is almost done so Kevin and Adam
asked to join Roberto's New multiversal
Avengers odinson Hyperion Abyss the last
one in existence and one of the
gardeners created by the builders ex
nihilo after Amadeus Cho is captured
Beast is able to hack into Tony Stark's
files at Avengers Tower but the
Illuminati are still on the run and
t'challa joins up with them to inform
them that like Olympus wakanda Has
Fallen tarax the truly enlightened pulls
a truly dick move and informs the United
Nations that yes the world is indeed
ending while the shield Avengers catch
up with what the Illuminati and Roberto
De Costa are up to Invisible Woman Susan
Richards later secretly meets up with
her husband Reed who she's been working
with all this time and gives him a note
from their super duper genius daughter
Valeria the note says you can't win time
to start figuring out how not to lose
ouch thanks for the vote of confidence
daughter
one shot energy huh okay I'll try it
oh yeah
[Applause]
whoa what is one shot's Focus chew do
[Music]
whoa one shot really is all you need
begin your transformation with one shot
energy today by going to
oneshotenergy.com new rockstars for 10
off your order some more members of
Roberto lacosta's New Avengers
Spider-Woman Jessica Drew and black
widow Natasha Romanov sneak into wakanda
and are almost spotted by Proxima
midnight and her hubby corvus glaive who
are bragging about having destroyed 14
realities so far those jerks no one else
on their team knows that they're there
but Jess and Nat are going to
potentially free the cabal's captive
Tony Stark who they've tracked down
until they talked to Tony and his damn
ego gets in the way Tony doesn't think
he's in the wrong at all after all his
Illuminati plans and so Jess and Nat
walk away woof Tony come on man then
Roberto starts laying out his plans he's
talked with Cyclops leader of the X-Men
who said he had a Phoenix egg which is
terrifying Roberto reveals he's got a
man on the inside of the Illuminati
former X-Man Beast who's been feeding
him Intel also Jess and Nat formerly of
The Shield Avengers have been feeding
him until 2. Roberto's got all the Intel
basically Steve Rogers has apparently
been putting together some secret plans
himself but Roberto has been Gathering
Power put in the Earth by ex nihilo like
self-sustenance in the form of the
children of the Sun a self-defense
mechanism in the form of pod a human
girl bonded with an alien system armor
the power of evolution in the form of
validator a Canadian superhero with a
Time fluctuating energy field and Sean
Chi who was able to access the power of
replication and who can now make an army
of Shang cheese dope so in hopes of
finding the decay of the Multiverse
Roberto De Costa's multiversal Avengers
along with a bunch of the builders
gardeners the ex nihilai plural are sent
across the Multiverse to the Temple of
the black priests in the nothing space
of destroyed universes the priests look
pretty Freaky Deaky so obviously The
Avengers start kicking their asses but
the black priests defend themselves
handily and take out a bunch of EX
nihili then odinson calls on the power
of a hammer From Another Universe the
hammer of Thor the Unworthy Thor with
two r's whose owner was apparently a
monstrous brute and odinson starts
kicking asses again then wouldn't you
know it the leader of the black priests
the great eye appears and it's none
other than Dr Steven strange it was all
a misunderstanding strange in the black
priests are trying to save the
Multiverse not destroy it in fact he
tells the Avengers they need to defeat a
group called The Ivory Kings and someone
called rabam ala to truly stop the end
of everything and he's not lying back on
Earth in Espana the Illuminati send a
message to shield for them to track down
and boy do they it kinda looks like the
shield Avengers might have the
Illuminati on the ropes but then the new
Avengers led by Sunspot arrive in
desperation Steve Rogers and Maria Hill
throw an emotionally neutered
sociopathic Bruce Banner under their
control From Another Dimension off the
Helicarrier to join The Fray below then
the Shang Chi Army drops in from
sunspots ship above the Helicarrier and
then Rogers pulls his secret move a
brand new team of Mighty Avengers Luke
Cage white tiger Spider-Man Peter Parker
blue Marvel She-Hulk Powerman Victor
Alvarez and Spectrum Monica Rambo and
this is just the coolest team ever I
love them they're great but it's a
double triple quadruple cross as Reed
Richards plays his finishing move asking
his wife to shut everybody down
Invisible Woman incapacitates everyone
on the battlefield and shows up with
Medusa Black Bolt and Namor surprise
he's back on the good guy side kind of
in a flashback in wakanda King tachaka
gives his son t'challa a king's blade
much later but still in the past
t'challa gives the blade to his sister
shuri and after the fall of necropolis
she gives it back to him and asks him to
quote put it where it belongs in the
present all parties present begin to
talk but only after Steve Rogers demands
that Neymar Richards Beast even t'challa
turn themselves in when this is over for
their crimes everyone agrees except
t'challa in any case Namor and the
Illuminati go over their plan to take
out the kebab all during the next
incursion were Namor plans to betray
them the plan works Namor makes his
planned Escape except before he can
Black Panther and Black Bolt appear in
front of Namor black panther betrays
Namo stabs him with the king's Blade
putting it where it belongs to make sure
he paid for the fall of wakanda and
Black Bolt yells farewell to the
Submariner knocking him back down to the
planet where he's stuck with the cabal I
guess Namor fished around and found out
Reed then explains everything to The
Avengers including that there are only
less than two dozen universes left and
that they'll avoid all the remaining
incursions until the last one Dr Doom
and the molecule man disappeared from
Earth 616 and landed somewhere in a
white void Reed says he doesn't know
what'll happen in the end and t'challa
tells Steve Rogers they tried a bunch of
things to prevent this but nothing
worked just then Hank Pym appears and
says he found the ivory Kings also known
as the beyonders before we jump into
what the hell Hank Pym learned about the
Multiverse I gotta tell you about our
universe which is filled with new
Rockstar's merch and it's the best way
to get into the Star Wars spirit for
Ahsoka so pick up a tea from our new
World Series line we've imagined a
softball league from a galaxy far far
away with teams from kashyyk Kessel and
Beyond the designs come in three-quarter
baseball shirts the wide striped Sleeve
football tees and in regular tees
embrace the light and dark side of the
nerd jock Spectrum at the same time and
if you're looking to soak up Ahsoka you
can grab the fulcrum balance or Galactic
graffiti tees for your next watch party
and if you think nerd Riot isn't working
on a really cool line of designs for
Loki season two you've probably been
eating too much of that toxic green pie
from the TVA break room because they are
join the riot over at nerd riot.shop six
months ago in reality 1610 also known as
the home of Ultimate Marvel Comics Nick
Fury recruited Reed Richards to begin
contingency plans for World threatening
events now Richards confirms he's killed
67 realities to save his own in reality
616 in shiars base Imperial Guard member
Mentor confirms something with the
magistor of the shiar Empire gladiator
who later confers with the heads of
Galactic Empires like the cree The Brood
the squirrel and annihilus of the
Negative Zone these assembled parties
agree that they need to destroy Earth so
that the rest of the universe can live
back in reality 1610 Richards now
calling himself the maker finds the
cabal who have escaped their trap set
for them by the Illuminati because the
world they were on that was set to be
destroyed was also about to deal with a
second incursion connecting them to this
Reed Richards Universe reality1610 okay
so Hank Pym tells the rest of the
Illuminati about the white Lords from
Wild space the beyonders how the
beyonder they dealt with in the original
Secret Wars comic miniseries from the
80s was a child unit visually modified
to mimic what it could perceive playing
with toys but these other beyonders are
not children and they deal with
universes plural not just one Universe
it took Pym 163 days to travel through
dying universes to find a superstation
of of refugee Builders from hundreds of
dead universes the builders found where
the ivory Kings were located and went
there but it was a trap Captain Britain
Brian Braddock then shows up to the
Illuminati and confirms this the
multiversal Captain Britain Corps did
the opposite of what Hank Did they sent
a beacon that the beyonders followed to
their Starlight Citadel and only one
Captain Britain Brian survived Pym saw
the beyonders kill celestials of every
Universe then abstract entities were
talking eternity the in-betweener Lord
Chaos Master order and infinity of every
universe and finally The Living Tribunal
of every remaining reality so Pym said
in the final days of the Marvel Universe
Our Heroes make plans in the Baxter
building Black Panther went over the
multiversal Lifeboat he designed for
Reed who took his daughter's advice also
in New York City Smasher Izzy Kane got
recalled back to the Imperial Guard
after spending time with Sam and her
baby Imperial Guard member Oracle tells
Gladiator not to destroy Earth but
Mentor tells him they must so Gladiator
makes the call and alien armadas head to
Earth the Guardians of the Galaxy
Star-Lord Gamora Drax Rocket Raccoon and
Groot intercept that call and go to
Earth to Warn its Heroes and Rocket
calls them all idiots for wanting to
defend it instead of just leaving for
safety classic rocket Unearthed 1903 990
there is a door to the library of Worlds
and the great eye of the black priests
Doctor Strange gives the order to attack
and try and take the door but a Black
Swan escapes through it strange in the
order open the door and track the Black
Swan who they'll need to get to rabam
Allah but it's a trap into a void where
no one can speak words the source of the
black priest's power the entire order is
all killed except for strange who's then
captured and taken to see rabam Allah
himself who is none other than Dr
freaking Doom Victor Von Doom tells
Stephen he's ready for war and he shows
him Owen Reese the molecule man and
Reese is observing the beyonders at the
remains of Earth
112006 a shattered map maker World The
multiversal Avengers see a
non-functional map maker who they will
need to get to the Ivory Kings Adam the
night mask capable of navigating the
Dreamscape of human potential boy put
that on your resume sacrifices himself
to transport The Avengers to where they
need to go because the cost of his power
is temporal regression and he de-ages
himself to pre-life The Avengers are
confronted by two beings who claim they
are Beyond understanding Beyond
acquiescence Beyond Justice Beyond The
Avengers The X Nai hellai fully realized
the beyonder's current form and ex-ni
hello and Abyss sacrifice themselves to
reshape the beyonder into a tree the
other beyonder disarms Thor stabs the
star brand blinds one eye of Hyperion
but Kevin can't contain his power and
explodes destroying the remaining
beyonder then many more beyonders come
through the hole in space Thor becomes
worthy again So Unworthy to lift Thor
with two r's Hammer he and Hyperion fly
into battle one last time it's gonna
start getting sad y'all we learned the
Illuminati free Tony Stark from his cage
in necropolis before Rogers and the
shield Avengers arrived just so they
didn't risk starting up the Stark Rogers
beef again Gladiator of the shiyar
Empire gives warning to the people of
Earth before their attack and then Reed
Richards gives Steve Rogers access to a
Tony Stark plan Stark built an automated
control system for the Planet Killer
ship they captured during the Builder
War Smasher respectfully denied going
back to the Imperial Guard and it was
cool and DeCosta International orbiting
satellites fire at the alien Armada from
Earth while the Planet Killer Fires at
the Armada from space but the satellites
lose power and then Gladiator sends the
annihilation wave to destroy the Planet
Killer ship then the Illuminati pull off
some other insane plan all thanks to
Tony Stark this brings us to the
molecule man Owen Reese this guy has
always been kind of a b or c-list
Fantastic Four villain even though he's
extremely powerful powerful enough to
reshape reality at a molecular level
which is why he's called the molecule
man that that white void we saw earlier
was in fact Rhys and doom traveling back
through time to Owen Reese's origin as
the molecule man he reveals to Doom that
he's the beyonder's bomb to end the
Multiverse a singular being across all
of space and time with a single shared
Consciousness Rhys explains that if he
dies his Universe goes with it and that
Doom will have to stop the beyonders by
going back in time and killing molecule
men across realities Rhys will
undoubtedly lose his grip on his sanity
and not be able to help so Doom will
need to start a religion to gather that
help Victor Von Doom will have to become
the great Destroyer rabam ala Rhys tells
Doom that he will become the knife and
to put it where it needs to go I got
chills we see this plan enacted Doom
Witnesses the first multiversal
incursion and recruits his multiversal
black swans Doom created the incursions
to begin with because he and Rhys were
killing other molecule men the beyonders
try to stop Doom's actions by having map
makers chart realities where molecule
man had died and back in the present
Victor tells Stephen Strange that the
beyonders could never stop him or go
back in time to stop him because they
are linear for all their power they
can't time travel baby then Doom strange
and Rhys confront the beyonders and all
goes white this is what caused the
Multiverse to narrow down to less than
two dozen and over in the last issue of
Miles Morales the Ultimate Spider-Man
Spider-Man Miles Morales was getting so
good at what he does getting to a point
in his career where he was able to take
down his universe as Dr Doom
single-handedly just kicking that dude's
entire ass miles and the rest of his
family and friends and even enemies
wouldn't be able to escape the collapse
of the Multiverse Spidey looked up into
the sky to see another Earth in an
incursion so yes Tony Stark uses the
sun's power to destroy the entire alien
Armada back in reality 616 and on Earth
1610 the maker invites Nick Fury and
Hawkeye to the city where he reveals
he's been working on defending their
reality for a year back on Earth 616
t'challa informs president Barack Obama
that everyone's time is up in less than
six hours then back on Earth 1610
Richards informs Fury he just killed
another world so that there are only two
left and Thanos warns Fury that the
final world Earth 616 is full of the
greatest heroes you have ever met the
Valiant the courageous and that they
better find a way to kill them all so
Fury prepares his Earth's Heroes to
defend it both Earths prepare for the
end of the universe and Steve Rogers
spends his final moments kicking Tony
Stark's ass I guess he can do this all
day until the end of the line but it's
not the end it's all to be continued in
2015's Secret Wars and what an ending
how much of time Runs Out will influence
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and its
Multiverse Saga only time will tell
thanks so much for letting me tell you
all about these Comics remind her to go
read them yourself if you're interested
follow me over at Heroes reforged on
YouTube and we'll see you next time bye
thank you
[Music]